— Христос Воскрес.
— Воістину Воскрес.
— Як cправи?
— Нормально. Краще всіх.
Це дуже добре.
Звичайно. Так ще й літом буде.
Буде палатка. Це вам потім дадуть знати.
На Комунарів буде палатка.
Але десь протягом двох тижнів.
Буде. Буде.
Тільки не пий, не пий!
А що ж робити?
Слухай, не пити!
Добре, бувай.
— До зустрічі.
— Так, до зустрічі.
Це з нашої сім'ї теж — бездомні.
Вони якраз жаліються на те,
що як закінчилась нічліжка в лікарні
то вони тепер тут в парку.
Коли була ця нічліжка,
це було дуже добре, бо ми туди приходили.
Але ми приходили з дітьми і з молоддю.
Наприклад, бувало так,
що молодь ліпила вареники.
Принесли їм вечерю.
А вони відчули себе людьми.
Оце тут наша столова.
Щоденна столова.
Тут біля кухні.
Вона для тих, хто тут проживає,
для гостей, що приходять.
Часто в родинах не можуть звести кінці з кінцями.
Прийшовши на вечірнє богослужіння або так,
то вже автоматично у нас і спільна вечеря.
Це є парафія. Окрім неї є
спільнота чоловіків «Лицарі Колумба».
Є спільнота «Матері в молитві» —
жінки, які єднаються.
Спільнота молоді з інвалідністю.
Є спільнота «Пласт» український,
для дітей, для підлітків, юнаків.
Починається з молитви.
Від 7 до 9 години маємо спільні молитви.
Потім сніданок, а потім уже біганина.
♪ Хорошії гості...  ♪
На всі сторони.
♪ ...за столом. ♪
Кухня. Тут є віконце, через яке видають
обіди для бездомних.
Вони вже там потихеньку збираються,
ми о 13:30 кожного дня годуємо їх.
Сьогодні похолодало —
я їм чаю гарячого зроблю.
Ми сьогодні зустрічали цих бездомних.
Ця п'яна жінка — вона хрестилась
переді мною.
Але це було...
Значить вона зустріла
приклад для наслідування, ікону.
Хтось, хто звернув і на неї увагу.
Фактично ці люди...
Ну кому вони потрібні?
А вони теж люди.
То як робили Святу вечерю на Різдво,
включали колядки –
це було надзвичайно емотивно.
Декотрі так плакали, як малі діти,
що і їсти не могли:
треба було їм потім запакувати їжу.
Для багатьох з них це був перший раз.
Багато з них мали батьків, які їх народили,
але ніколи в родині не були.
У них раніше ніколи не було святкового столу,
вони не пам’ятають такого.
Я родом зі Словаччини.
Змалечку нас збирали
біля радіо – цілу родину.
У нас було таке маленьке радіо.
І кожної неділі була
українська Служба Божа з Ватикану.
І якось так змалечку в мене таке було,
що я, коли виросту, піду до радіо.
Буду в радіо теж службу співати.
В підлітковому віці я
безбожно закохався в дівчину.
Вона теж була віруюча й побожна.
Тоді вже була церква, були священники.
Одного разу вона запитала мене:
«Ким ти хочеш бути?»
І я їй так....
Думаю собі: «Ну ким [хочу бути]»?
Ким ти захочеш – я буду!
І потім почала розказувати, як вона
вчилась в іншому місті в середній школі.
Ранком іде в школу, заходить завжди в церкву.
І там такий чудовий, класний священник.
І це для мене було: ну от подобається
тобі священник — чого не бути священником?
Але це було якби....
Я потім усвідомив, що я приховував це в собі.
Вона допомогла мені не боятись цього.
Зрозуміти, що дійсно
це моє покликання – бути священником.
Правда потім... ми розійшлися.
Після армії я вступив в семінарію і вивчився.
В 1993 році греко-католицький єпископ
з Ужгорода дав запит,
що потрібна допомога на Закарпатті.
І я якось так наважився.
Нові пригоди.
Після великого наводнення на Закарпатті
декілька родин переселились
в околиці Мелітополя.
Родин із моєї парафії.
Вони підтримували контакт зі мною.
Вони могли виплакатись в телефон.
Казали: «Тут нема свят».
Ми зі священниками приїхали подивитися.
Потім сказали: «Добре. Організуйте громаду»
Тоді я зрозумів, що церква це одне —
їй потрібний священник.
Прийшла ця думка — як не я, то хто?
Моє перше враження від Мелітополя
було, що це таке сіре місто.
Всюди цегла. Без кольорів.
Місто, яке не мало належного центру.
Дороги розбиті.
Там, де наша церква,
то сам цеглу бив і засипав ями,
щоб можна було проїхати.
Всюди корупція.
Не можна сказати, що тепер все ідеально,
але є таке враження, що світає.
Є світанок.
Тут є наш дім милосердя.
Всі квіти зацвіли.
— Христос воскрес.
— Воістину воскрес.
Христос воскрес.
— Що спите?
— Так.
Христос воскрес. Як ви?
А це дівчата тепер...
Хотів би тут міні пекарню зробити.
Тоді хоча б дві людини мали роботу.
Хати дешеві, їх можна придбати й дати,
але з іншого боку, треба шукати спосіб,
як їх поставити на ноги.
Багато старих людей виживають.
Це тому, що нема моральної сили.
Нема цієї позитивної сили.
От це що в нас всередині.
Ця генерація, яка мала б
передавати життєву мудрість.
Вони здеформовані аморальними поглядами
з телебачення і різних ЗМІ.
Важливо те, щоб хоча б церква, там де я,
була осередком позитиву.
Завтра отець Сашко має три роки священства.
Приїдьте, треба буде його привітати.
Добре.
– Добре?
— Куди? Давай. Зараз?
В Мелітополь.
Не через годину, моментально.
Що-що?
Як підтримка потрібна тобі —
так підтримка потрібна і іншим.
— Розумієш?
— Ну я просто не хочу.
А я що примусово тебе заберу? Не заберу.
Ти станеш дорослим тоді,
коли своє «не хочу»
зможеш відкласти в сторону.
Це «не хочу» знаєш як називається фахово?
–Вийди на трішки.
–Добре.
[шепоче] Це називається бунт.
А ти бунтарем не хочеш бути.
Але це вік такий бунтарський.
Ну я не хочу.
Так я тобі й кажу.
Через ці бунти треба пройти.
Кожного разу переломлюючи свій бунт —
ти будуєш свій характер. Добре?
–Ну я не хочу.
–Добре. В неділю будеш на службі?
–На службі? На службі я буду.
–Добре.
Ми з друзями домовлялися.
Відкрийте. Сідай тут.
В цю хату, що ми заходили...
Але там дуже важкохвора бабуся.
Була така ситуація, що вона дуже важко захворіла.
Терміново треба було лікувати в лікарні.
Але ця Іра, що була,
вона матір одиночка двох дітей.
Тому в них кожного місяця є проблема,
як звести кінці з кінцями.
Правда і шукав кошти, щоб її підняти.
І тепер...
І вона потім, як єрихонська труба,
трубила всюди, яка ми церква,
що допомагаємо людям.
Праці дуже багато.
Почуваємо себе як батьки —
багатодітною, великою-великою сім'єю.
Нам завжди так говорили,
що священик повинен завжди бути вагітний.
Це означає дозволити, щоб народжувались
нові і нові діти для спільноти церкви.
Важливо щоб, наприклад, вони бачили не священика, який є «солодкий».
А такого, який живе й працює до виснаження.
Який і падає.
Який ввечері ледве ноги тягне за собою.
Не такого, що прогуляв цю енергію —
а віддав все своїм дітям!
Набагато важче було на Закарпатті
[ніж в Мелітополі].
Тим, що греко-католицькі храми, історично, позабирали православні московські.
То там була агресія набагато більша.
Це середовище, що в Мелітополі,
не є настільки релігійне.
Були й випадки. Вночі приходили,
будили мене п'яні, погрожували.
Я поки міг, то ще їх і нагодував, вислухав.
Агресію, зло можна подолати лише добром.
Місто трансформується.
Я думаю, що Мелітополь буде на першому місці
в Україні серед чудо-позитивних змін.
Наприклад є фонди і для людей
з інвалідністю, і для шкіл.
Наприклад, одну школу повністю
відремонтували. Це прекрасно.
Зайшли б до лікарні, там все ремонтують,
роблять, працюють.
Робота кипить!
Всюди, всюди відчутно, що з цієї
посткомунісичної руїни починає кипіти життя.
Це не є лише моя думка. Багато хто так говорить:
«Мале місто, яке проходить величезні зміни».
З богом.
Так, поїхали.
Думаю, що вдалось створити таку спільноту людей,
які можуть підтримати,
яким не байдуже те, що я бачу.
Головне бажання,
щоб було кому передати ці вартості.
Помагати людям. Щоб любили себе.
Щоб виходили з цих комплексів
щодо України, щодо мови, щодо пісні.
Хотів би бути і надалі
«пальцем, який показує».
Не я префект.
А є хтось, хто дає силу.
А ми всі до цього покликані.
А ще можемо разом творити цю родину
і будувати взаємні стосунки,
порозуміння, взаємопрощення.
І тоді відроджується ця творчість.
Бачимо, що можемо щось.
Хтось посадить квіточку – і це вже щось.
А разом – можемо багато чого!